We covered I think it was two weeks ago the very
healthy incomes of Jared Kushner and his wife,
Ivanka Trump, while they were working in
the White House, earning some 400 million
or so dollars between the two of them. Again,
remember, while they were advising Donald Trump
on policy and if Ivanka was meeting with world
leaders, sitting in for the secretary of state,
we now have income data for Donald Trump.
And Donald Trump is and this is the key word.
Donald Trump is admitting to making
more than one point six billion dollars
in revenue and income during his four years as
president of the United States. That's roughly
four hundred million dollars per year. This is
based on a review by CRU Citizens for Responsible
Ethics Watchdog. I doubt that's what it
is. I always forget what Cruz stands for,
but there are very good organization that has
reviewed Donald Trump's financial disclosures,
and Donald Trump very publicly took credit for and
bragged about donating his salary. Four hundred
and forty thousand dollars a year, I believe
it is. But that ended up representing less than
zero point one percent of the revenue and income
that he has disclosed during his presidency.
So really no big sacrifice. And I think that
there's a couple of different stories here.
On the one hand, Donald Trump's presidency did
significant damage to his brand reputation,
lots of things, removing the Trump name
from them, buildings, condo buildings,
et cetera. Donald Trump's hospitality revenue down
dramatically, many of his hotels even before the
pandemic, doing not well. The pandemic has only
accelerated that, of course. But at the same time,
you have to understand that there are all sorts
of other sources of revenue for Donald Trump,
including licensing and other properties that
Trump has an interest in but don't have the Trump
name on them. Many people may not even know that
they're necessarily Trump affiliated properties,
golf courses and so many other things. Some
of these are in Europe. We know, of course,
of Turnberry in and Aberdeen in Scotland,
two of Donald Trump's golf courses there.
And this has been a very profitable presidency
for Donald Trump. Donald Trump and his family
repeatedly said, we're sort of taking
a you know, we're taking a hit here.
My life was great before being president. And,
you know, I was making all sorts of money and I'm
separating myself from all these businesses and
all of this stuff made a big show of putting a
big stack of papers in front of him during
the transition period in 2016, claiming that
he he is going to be disassociating himself from
all of these businesses. Well, turns out that he
still earned a ton a ton of money. And what this
really makes me think of is the stunning hypocrisy
with which right wingers can honestly say Bernie
has a million dollars at nearly 80 years old
and after earning six figures for decades
as a member of Congress and now the Senate,
Bernie, has a million dollars in three houses.
Donald Trump earned four hundred million
dollars per year while president of the United
States. Jimmy Carter, when he was president,
severed ties with his family's peanut farm to
avoid even the possibility of the appearance
of the perception of impropriety. And Donald
Trump made four hundred million dollars per year
and. You hear nothing from his followers, it
shouldn't really surprise us. And then the last
thing is, as of course with Trump, he's admitting
to one point six billion while president.
How much else is there and with Donald Trump, we
know he's very willing to say that a particular
building is worth a lot if he needs to use it as
collateral for a loan or not worth much at all,
if it's to reduce the value of his assets for tax
purposes, real estate tax purposes or whatever the
case may be, Donald Trump is admitting to one
point six million in income and revenue while
he was president. What else is there? How
much has been funneled to his various kids?
We know that with campaign donations, he was
regularly putting his family members on staff,
Laura Trump and many, many others. We may
never know the full scope of it. Sadly,